warren buffett is one of the best
investors of all time
boasting an average annual rate of
return of 20.5 percent
since 1965. however over the last decade
berkshire hathaway has actually slightly
lagged behind s p 500
more importantly in early 2019 warren
buffett actually revealed that he's had
a quote
tough time trying to beat s p 500 so
what happened to the oracle of omaha
before we get started here
we should address that just because
warren buffett has struggled to beat the
market
doesn't mean that he's been doing bad by
any means
over the last 10 years berkshire
hathaway has produced a solid annual
return of 11.08
meanwhile the s p 500 has returned
11.379 percent without dividends
reinvested
and 13.537 percent with the dividends we
invested
so though warren buffett did lag behind
s p 500
he didn't necessarily perform poorly
with that being said
warren buffett's returns over the past
10 years are only a fraction of what
they used to be
so let's take a look at some of the
driving factors behind this
starting with the size of berkshire
hathaway berkshire hathaway is currently
the 12th largest company
in the world with a market cap of 543
billion dollars
generally company executives and
shareholders are ecstatic as their
company grows year
after year but in the case of berkshire
hathaway
this has actually turned into a major
problem you see
warren buffett has more money than he
can effectively invest
as of may 2020 warren buffett was
actually sitting on 137 billion dollars
worth of cash
here's the thing warren buffett is a
value investor
meaning that he likes to buy companies
with strong financials and plenty of
growth left
the problem is that value companies are
not as common
and generally have lower market caps in
the billions of dollars or in the tens
of billions
for the average person this wouldn't be
a problem
but when you have 137 billion dollars to
deploy
i think it's clear how this can quickly
turn into a major obstacle
warren buffett has revealed that at this
point in time
there's only a few hundred american
companies that are big enough for him to
make a reasonable investment in
many of which he already owns something
that has further made value investing
difficult for warren buffett
is the market sentiment over the past
year as we all know
the pandemic caused a massive sell-off
in the stock market in spring of 2020.
however warren buffett didn't buy the
crash like he did throughout 2008 and
2009.
in fact he actually sold all of his
airline stocks near the bottom of the
crash
from a rational perspective this makes
sense as the airline industry was likely
going to take years to fully recover
most airlines were likely going to end
up burning billions of dollars
and many were unlikely to even survive
the pandemic
despite this though investors have bid
up airline stocks
anyways take southwest for example
between 2017
and 2020 their stock price hovered in
the mid 50s
during the pandemic southwest stock
would drop all the way to 23.87
but since then their stock price has
almost fully recovered
standing at 45 today in that perfect
world
this would mean that southwest is
operating at about 80 of the capacity
that they were operating at
before the pandemic in reality though in
the third quarter of 2020
southwest lost 1.2 billion dollars
indicating that
at this point in time southwest is
nowhere close to fully recovering
unlike the 2008 crash investing in
stocks is much more accessible to the
average person
especially with the rise of mobile
investing apps consequently
many potential value investments have
been bid up before the underlying
company has actually started to make a
turnaround
making it nearly impossible to find real
value investments in the market
aside from struggling to find places to
put his money warren buffett has also
been outperformed by another segment of
the market
which is good stocks over the past
decade
investors have flocked towards companies
with enormous future potential
even if they're overvalued on paper for
instance
one of the most popular growth company
investments has of course been
amazon on paper amazon hasn't had the
greatest profit margins
to be honest they've had terrible profit
margins and
aws has really padded their retail
deficit throughout the decade
however amazon has had enormous growth
in terms of revenue
market dominance and prime members as a
result
investors have chosen to value amazon
based on their future profitability
as opposed to their current
profitability another popular example of
a growth company
is no doubt tesla and their promising
outlook in terms of the ev
and av markets anyways a lot of the
growth in the s p 500
in recent times has been thanks to these
growth stocks while value stocks have
underperformed the broader market
moving on warren buffett has made some
bad investments
as well as we previously discussed
warren buffet has limited investment
opportunities
in the market so he shifted some of his
focus towards growing current
investments
in 2015 berkshire hathaway and 3g
capital would decide that it was a good
idea to merge together craft
and heinz they were both monster food
companies
so combining them should only make them
stronger
right well though that works out in
theory
it didn't work out so well in practice
right after the merger was completed
the two companies decided that they
should help the other company using
their strengths
heinz had a global reach while craft was
mostly concentrated within north america
so the two decided to expand craft's
popular sub brands to international
markets
meanwhile they also spent significant
time on trying to pull the resources to
cut down on prices
and reach more people however the focus
on international expansion
and cutting down costs resulted in them
losing sight of major trends within the
marketplace
such as a trend towards healthier foods
this loss in focus
along with some poor management
decisions has sent craft heinstock
tumbling down to the low 30s
which is only a third of where the stock
stood just a couple of years ago
clearly even the best investors have
their fair share of losses
despite decades of experience and that
brings me on to the next major shortfall
for berkshire hathaway
which is her long investment history
warren buffett has led berkshire
hathaway since 1965
and over the many many decades their
diversity has slowly
but consistently grown diversity is
great when you're looking to create a
safe investment portfolio
but at the same time diversity largely
hinders the growth rate of the
investment portfolio
risk and reward are directly tied
together when it comes to investments
as a result it's not a surprise that the
reward has slowly declined
as the risk declined now berkshire's
holdings
aren't quite as diverse as something
like the s p 500 but
they nonetheless hold quite a bit as of
september 2020
berkshire hathaway has a solid 49
different holdings they continue to hold
significantly more capital in companies
where they have greater conviction
such as apple bank of america and
coca-cola
however it doesn't take very much
diversification to significantly limit
growth rates
let's take apple for instance berkshire
hathaway holds a whopping
137 billion dollars worth of apple stock
which accounts for about half of their
portfolio
in 2020 apple stock surged a massive 70
percent
if one's entire portfolio was just apple
stock which is not a good idea
then their portfolio would likewise go
70 percent
but what if only 50 of their portfolio
was apple stock
and the rest were average stocks that
match the market and return let's say
10 in such a scenario the portfolio's
overall return over the year would be 40
which is still a phenomenal return
however
it's only a fraction of 70 percent and
this becomes extremely clear
over time if both portfolios started
with 100
after the first year the diversified
portfolio would only be 30
behind the non-diversified portfolio but
if this phenomenon continues for 10
years
the diversified portfolio starts to fall
behind significantly
at the end of 10 years the diversified
portfolio would stand at 2
892 while the non-diversified portfolio
would stand at a whopping
20 thousand as you can see though the
diversified portfolio enjoyed return
rates that were over half the rate of
the diversified portfolio
the diversified portfolio only ends up
with less than 15
of the total returns this is why warren
buffett and most of the top billionaires
hate diversification
in fact warren buffett has stated quote
diversification is a protection against
ignorance
it makes very little sense for those who
know what they're doing
now this isn't to say that you shouldn't
diversify
but if you're looking to beat the market
a concentrated portfolio is essential
and though warren buffett is well aware
of this principle
he hasn't been able to do much about it
he's at a point where he either chooses
to diversify
or he leaves the money in cash which is
even worse
thus as berkshire hathaway has grown
warren buffett has been forced to
diversify
which has substantially hurt his gains
at the end of the day
if you haven't noticed yet there's one
overarching theme throughout all of this
which is that with time berkshire
hathaway as more or less
become the market itself in the early
days when they were small
nimble and concentrated berkshire had to
enjoy gains of 30
40 and even 50 per year but
as they have grown in size they have
become too big to effectively invest
all of their money as a result they've
been forced to diversify their portfolio
and settle for smaller gains in the end
though it looks like the glory days of
warren buffett are slowly coming to an
end it's no question that his investing
philosophies
and legacy will live on for centuries to
come
what do you guys think is the main
reason for berkshire hathaway's
declining returns
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys thought this video explained
the various obstacles warren buffett
faces
well and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]